ancien directeur de campagne du candidat
emmanuel macron et actuel de chef de
cabinet du ministre d'état ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur girier comme je lé
fais avec vous tous toutes les
personnalités auditionnées je dois vous
rappeler qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission des lois doté des
prérogatives d'une commission d' enquête
parlementaire serait passible de cinq
ans d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
d'amendé
je vous invite à prêter serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité ait
levé la main droite et dit je le jure je
jure de dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité
je vous remercie je vous propose de
prendre la parole point bref exposé
liminaire après lequel nos rapporteur
puis les membres de la commission des
lois et les collègues qui le
souhaiteront même nos membres de la
commission des lois vous poseront un
certain nombre de questions
vous avez la parole je vous remercie
monsieur le président mesdames et
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
permettez moi tout d'abord de vous
adresser mes salutations respectueuses
mon propos liminaire sera conçu afin
d'observer la demande formulée par
monsieur le président de la commission
tout en étant le plus précis possible
pour apporter ma contribution à vos
travaux
tout d'abord la chronologie des faits
tels que je les ai vécus je ne
reviendrai pas sur ce que le ministre
d'état monsieur gérard collomb vous a
exposé sur le climat de violences du
printemps dernier le 1er mai je
travaillais à beauvau comme une grande
partie du cabinet ministériel afin de
suivre le déroulement d'une journée qui
s'annonçait délicate et s'est avéré
d'une grande brutalité à 19h45
j'ai accompagné le ministre d'état à la
préfecture de police il s'est d'abord
entretenu avec le préfet dans le bureau
de ce dernier
avant de tenir un point presse dans la
cour de la préfecture la délégation
s'est ensuite rendue dans la salle de
commandement afin de saluer l'ensemble
des fonctionnaires de police le préfet a
présenté les images de vidéo-protection
illustrant la tension encore palpable en
cette fin de journée alors que nous
étions présents depuis cinq minutes
environ
une tape sur l'épaule m'a conduit en me
retournant à découvrir la présence de
monsieur benalla ainsi que celle de
monsieur kraz que je connais tous les
deux j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir
j'ai été étonné à la fois de les voir en
ces lieux ne surcroît dans une tenue qui
m'a semblé inapproprié parce que trop
décontracté je souligne que le ministre
d'état se tenait au centre de la salle
de commandement à une dizaine de mètres
de nous environ choix est également
précisé que le ministre d'état n'a pas
fait d'accolades à monsieur benalla il
l'a salué comme toutes les personnes
présentes le ministre que je connais de
longue date comme nombre d'entre vous
d'ailleurs n'est pas familier des
accolades et salut de manière très
courtoise les personnes qu'ils les
connaissent ou qui ne les connaissent
pas comme c'était ici le cas à 23 heures
j'accompagnais le ministre d'état sur le
parvis du commissariat du xiiie
arrondissement pour en déplacement en
présence du premier ministre venu saluer
et remercier les forces de sécurité
durement éprouvé le lendemain matin
mercredi 2 mai précisément à 8h02 j'ai
reçu un message dans chargé de mission
de l'elysée comportant un lien vers un
réseau social sur lequel était présentée
la fameuse vidéo sur laquelle
apparaissait messieurs benalla écrase je
les reconnais c'est ainsi que leurs
tenues identiques à celles qu'il portait
la veille en salle de commandement les
faits m'ont semblé suffisamment grave
pour que je transmette immédiatement le
lien vers cette vidéo à mon directeur de
cabinet ce que j'ai fait à 8h12 très
exactement vers 10 heures à l'issue de
la réunion d'états majors qu'il
présidait nous avons visionné tous les
deux cette vidéo dès lors le directeur
de cabinet du ministre d'état a pris la
tâche
du directeur de cabinet du président et
a été contacté par le préfet de police
de paris
il m'a confirmé s'être assurée que
l'autorité hiérarchique comme l'autorité
préfectorale était alertée s'agissant de
l'information du ministre d'état sur les
faits je ne reviens pas sur son agenda
qu'il vous a présenté lors de son
audition toutefois je vous confirme que
dès son retour de déjeuner
le directeur de cabinet et moi même lui
avons expliqué l'événement et montrer la
vidéo qu'il qualifie immédiatement
d'inacceptable nous lui avons exposé les
démarches entreprises par son directeur
de cabinet en direction de son homologue
de la présidence aux alentours de 23
heures
mon directeur de cabinet et moi même
avons fait un point il m'a fait part de
l' échange qu'il venait d'avoir avec le
directeur de cabinet du président
renseignements pris qui lui indiquait
que monsieur benalla s'était rendu dans
le cadre de ce maintien de l'ordre avec
son autorisation
mais sans être missionné par l'elysée
que monsieur benalla avait été doté par
la préfecture de police d'un équipement
de protection et enfin que les actes de
violences commis par monsieur benalla
était inacceptable et qu'il donnerait
lieu à des sanctions
nous avons dès lors considérer que la
situation était prise en compte et
informé dès le lendemain matin le
ministre d'état
s'agissant des 18 et 19 juillet j'ai été
informé le 18 à 13h30 par le service
presse de la présidente qu'une
journaliste allait publier en articles
relatifs à la vidéo informations que
j'ai immédiatement transmise à mon
directeur de cabinet puis évoquer
ensemble avec le ministre aux alentours
de 15h la parution de l'article révélera
de nouvelles informations en particulier
le port d'un brassard de police et d'un
équipement radio le ministre d'état a eu
l'occasion de vous exposer les
conséquences de celle-ci à savoir une
saisine igpn le 19 juillet dont le
rapport vous a été transmis vendredi
dernier
revenons-en à mes relations avec les
deux protagonistes
je les connais à des degrés différents
mais tous deux depuis la campagne du
candidat emmanuel macron dont comme
l'ordre du jour de votre commission l'a
mentionné
j'ai assuré la direction de campagne à
partir de janvier 2017
premièrement concernant monsieur benalla
c'est donc dans le cadre de la campagne
présidentielle que j'ai fait la
connaissance de monsieur benalla qui
assurait à titre salarié les fonctions
de directeur de la sûreté et de la
sécurité au cours de la campagne
j'ai appris à le connaître notre
relation est tout à fait cordiale et je
n'ai eu aucune remarque négative à
formuler ni sur son engagement ni sur
son comportement ni sur la qualité de
son travail depuis son entrée en
fonction au palais de l'elysée j'ai eu
des contacts réguliers avec lui si mon
interlocuteur du quotidien reste le chef
de cabinet monsieur benalla a aussi été
l'un des interlocuteurs entre les deux
chefferies de cabinet selon les dossiers
qu'il suivait j'ai eu des réunions
effectué des visites préparatoires ou
accompagné des déplacements auxquels
participent et mon ministre et dans
lesquelles monsieur benalla étaient
présents concernant monsieur kraz je les
croisais à de nombreuses reprises durant
la campagne présidentielle puisqu'il
occupait les fonctions de veilleur de
nuit pour la surveillance du siège et de
sécurisation de certains meetings gelée
par ailleurs rencontré depuis lors
d'événements politiques dont il assurait
la sécurité dans le cadre de son emploi
à la république en marche pour conclure
mon propos liminaire je souhaite
insister sur un point que les
différentes auditions menées ou la
presse ont laissé sous-entendre il a été
prétendu que monsieur benalla aurait pu
bénéficié de passe-droit auprès du
ministère de l'intérieur et notamment à
la faveur de notre relation
avant tout je le rappelle monsieur
benalla n'a bénéficié d'aucun traitement
privilégié par mon intermédiaire
je respecte profondément mes fonctions
et l' institution que je sers ne serait
ce que pour le laisser prétendre
j'affirme donc simplement mais de
manière très catégorique
que monsieur benalla ne m'a jamais
sollicité pour en équipement police dans
quelconque véhicule qu'il ne m'a jamais
sollicité pour en appui sur un poste de
sous-préfet auto extérieur qu il ne m'a
jamais sollicité pour l'obtention d'un
grade de lieutenant-colonel en qualité
de gendarme réserviste et que s'il m'a
effectivement parler de sa demande de
port d'armes qu'il avait formulée auprès
du ministre de l'intérieur
je n'ai donné aucune suite à cette
demande demande à laquelle le ministère
n'a pas réservé de suite favorable
enfin monsieur benalla ne m'a jamais
sollicité pour faciliter l'obtention
dans port d'armes auprès de la
préfecture de police de paris
autorisation qu'il obtiendra
ultérieurement
ce dont ni le ministre ni son cabinet ni
moi-même n'avons eu connaissance avant
la semaine dernière monsieur le
président madame et monsieur les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
voici les quelques éléments qui me
semblait nécessaire de porter à votre
connaissance afin de concourir à
l'indispensable établissement de la
vérité sur cette affaire dont vous en
conviendrez tout le monde se serait bien
passé je vous remercie monsieur le chef
de cabinet je vais vous posez moi même
une ou deux questions avant que nos
rapporteur ne le fasse vous avez pris
soin au début de votre intervention de
souligner le climat de violence c'est ce
sont les mots que vous avez utilisé du
printemps dernier à l'occasion des
manifestations du 1er mai est la grande
brutalité c'est aussi votre expression d
action qui se sont déroulés en marge de
ces manifestations est ce que vous
suggérez en insistant sur ce contexte
que les effectifs de police qui étaient
présents sur place se sont trouvés mis
en difficulté et est-ce que de votre
point de vue si tel était le cas ce
serait de nature à atténuer la faute qui
est reproché à monsieur benalla qui a
prêté main forte aux effectifs de police
présents à l'occasion de sa présence en
qualité d'observateurs monsieur le
monsieur le président ce n'est pas le
cas si j'ai soulevé le climat qui était
celui ci c'est pour montrer la tension
qui peut être celle du ministre ou de
son entourage
autour de ces événements je le rappelle
cette manifestation du 1er mai revêtez
une tonalité particulière et des risques
importants
les organisations syndicales souhaitent
inscrire leur manifestation autour des
projets de réforme du gouvernement
l'ultra gauche voulait faire de cette
journée un peu en sorte de point d'orgue
de la manifestation nous étions aussi
symboliquement dans le 50e anniversaire
de mai 68 et nous avions eu par nos
services de renseignement une alerte sur
un certain nombre d'activistes violent
néanmoins en othe lanka les éléments
relatifs à ce contexte ne doivent être
rapprochés de l'intervention de monsieur
benalla sur la contrescarpe ça va sans
dire mais ça va encore mieux en le
disant je vous en remercie et je
voudrais maintenant vous posez la
question du port d'armes et
c'est une situation assez singulière
vous avez rappelé vous-même que une
demande tu crois de deux demandes même
avait été adressée au ministre de
l'intérieur que ces demandes n'ont pas
obtenu une réponse favorable mais que le
préfet de police lui a délivré le board
homme est ce qu'il est réellement
possible que la préfecture de police
n'ait pas informé ni le cabinet ni les
services centraux du ministère de
l'intérieur de la délivrance d'un permis
de port d'armes ou un collaborateur du
président de la république dont on a
suffisamment souligné ces derniers temps
que sa seule qualité de collaborateur du
président de la république faisait
impressions sur des agents de la police
nationale
et je suppose que donc elle pouvait
faire impression aussi sur les services
centraux de la préfecture de police
comme du ministère au fond il ya une
sorte de discordance entre les
l'affirmation selon laquelle la
préfecture de police aurait agi seul et
le contexte général qu'on a souvent
décrit devant cette commission
monsieur le président comme j'ai pu
blesser au pied dans mon propos
liminaire ce n'est pas été informée
comme le ministre lui même a pu vous le
dire de la délivrance le 13 octobre 2010
est d'une autorisation de port d'armes
par monsieur bennama pour monsieur denis
alors si on fait un peu d'archéologie
une certaine information atteste que
monsieur benalla avait déjà demandé la
possibilité d'obtenir un port d'armes
pendant
la campagne de l'élection présidentielle
est ce que comme directeur de cabinet
plutôt directeur de campagne du candidat
emmanuel macron vous pouvez confirmer
cette information
je peux vous confirmer que monsieur
benalla disposait dans port d'armes dans
le cadre d' allah de la campagne
présidentielle
uniquement dans les locaux du siège de
la campagne
savez vous si la porter cette arme en
dehors des locaux du siège de la
campagne
pas à ma connaissance je vous remercie
et je vais donner la parole maintenant
un monsieur le président soeur merci
monsieur le président je voulais eux
monsieur chef de cabinet euh vous poser
de questions sur l'actualité récente
le journal libération a publié un
article et des vidéos faisant état d'
événement survenu trois heures avant des
événements de la contrescarpe et mettant
en cause monsieur benalla et monsieur
kraz avez vous connaissance de ces
événements
quand et si vous ne veut pas eu
connaissance comment l'expliquez vous je
n'ai pas eu connaissance de ces éléments
avant de lire tout comme vous l'article
de libération et de découvrir les
quelques secondes de vidéo qui
témoignerait de l'intervention de
monsieur benalla et monsieur kraz il y
apparaît en éléments nouveaux que je
n'avais pas vu jusqu'à présent c'est le
port d'un brassard par monsieur kraz au
delà je ne disposais pas de cette
information et au regard de précédentes
auditions qui ont pu avoir lieu
les autorités de la préfecture de police
lors de premières auditions elles mêmes
n'ont pas semblé avoir à leur
connaissance une intervention préalable
à celle de la contrescarpe
merci le deuxième question de monsieur
benalla a obtenu dans les conditions que
l'on sait une vidéo présentant les
événements qui l'ont précédé son
intervention
cette vidéo aurait été transmise à un
conseiller du président de la république
avez vous eu connaissance de cette vidéo
et quand en possédez vous une copie ou
quelqu'un du cabinet du ministre de
l'intérieur en possède-t-il une copie à
votre connaissance concernant cette
vidéo dont vous connaissez les
conditions dans laquelle elles ont été
obtenues
je tiens à affirmer que personne au
syndic du cabinet du ministre d'état n'a
eu connaissance de cette vidéo
nina vu cette vidéo nina transmis ou
posséder cette vidéo sous une quelconque
forme
au delà je crois que ces informations
sont désormais couvertes par le secret
de l'instruction et il appartiendra à la
justice de faire toute la lumière sur
ces fonds je vous remercie enfin eu une
troisième question avant de donner le
relais à ma collègue peut interroger le
24 juillet par notre commission monsieur
le ministre d'état gérard collomb a
déclaré vous concernant et s'agissant du
recrutement de monsieur ban à la 2e au
5e de la campagne présidentielle
je cite entre guillemets je ne pense pas
qu'il c'est à dire vous même et recruter
monsieur vénale a sinon il y aurait un
problème de confiance et verriers et je
n'apparais j'ajoute une phrase avec la
permission
président pouvez vous confirmer donc que
vous n'avez pas recruter monsieur ben
alla alors qu'on avait cru comprendre le
contraire
dans ces conditions comment s'est
effectuée exactement son recrutement et
enfin avez-vous joué un rôle dans son
recrutement ultérieure à la présidence
de la république j'en ai fini monsieur
messieurs girier très bien alors pour
vous répondre sur vos différentes
questions
tout d'abord recruter alexandre b n'a
lâché en marche
je n'ai pas recruter alexandre benalla
pour une raison bien simple d'abord les
recrutements étaient effectués par le
trésorier de la campagne les différents
chefs de pôles qui organisait cette
campagne présidentielle trois pôles en
pôle affaires générales en pôle
communication est en pôle opérations et
événementiel en l'occurrence la sécurité
dépend des du pôle opérations monsieur
benalla a été recruté en décembre 2016
or à ce moment là je n'avais pas
aptitude à recruter quiconque seul car
monsieur benalla a été recruté en
décembre et j'ai pris mes fonctions de
directeur de campagne au 1er janvier
comme je voulais dit en introduction
néanmoins je tiens l on tend à être
parfaitement précis et je confirme avoir
été avisé de son embauche
car j'étais alors le chef de cabinet de
la campagne comme cela apparaît
d'ailleurs dans un courriel qui est issu
des piratages des boîtes email de la
campagne présidentielle où nous avons
une mention vu avec jm g sur la deuxième
question c'est qu'est celle de la
confiance
vous connaissez les relations qui sont
celles d'un élu avec son collaborateur
d'un ministre avec son collaborateur
elles sont fondées sur un lien de
confiance j'avais donné cette
information au ministre d'état dès lors
il considère que nous sommes en
confiance lorsque je lui transmets cette
information je travaille dans son
environnement auprès de lui depuis
bientôt une dizaine d'années et je ne
doute pas du lien de confiance qui est
le nôtre
eu égard à mon engagement et ma loyauté
pour terminer et répondre sur le
troisième point je n'ai pas été saisi et
je crois tout simplement que je n'avais
pas mon mot à dire sur le recrutement de
monsieur benalla au palais de l'elysée
j'étais alors à beauvau en qualité de
chef de cabinet et je n'ai pas à porter
en quelconque jugement ni en quelconque
regard sur les recrutements qui sont
effectués à la présidence de la
république
merci merci monsieur girier madame
jourdain
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président vous avez
indiqué tout à l'heure monsieur gériez
avoir revu monsieur benalla au cours de
réunions ou de visites préparatoires
quel était son rôle de revoir monsieur
vénale à à l'issue de la période durant
laquelle il a fait l'objet d'une
suspension
j'ai eu l'occasion pour vous donner les
derniers exemples que j'ai en tête de
traiter avec lui de question de pure
protocole de placements dans les
tribunes officielles pour le défilé de
14 juillet d'accès ou d'organisations
périmétrique au palais de l'elysée pour
la venue de l'équipe de france de
football
je n'ai eu dans ce cadre là que des
relations liées au nouveau périmètre qui
était le sien en l'occurrence celui de
la gestion d'événements relevant du
palais de l'elysée madame jourdain
vous n'avez jamais eu l'occasion donc de
travailler avec lui antérieurement cette
rétrogradation jeu
vous répondez sur la période à l'issue
auparavant dès son arrivée au mois de
mai j'ai bien évidemment eu l'occasion
de travailler à de multiples reprises
avec lui dans les nombreux déplacements
qu'a pu effectuer le ministre d'état
avec le président de la république
madame jourdain
donc quel était son rôle dans ces lignes
monsieur benalla dans ses réunions dans
ses visites préparatoires ou dans ses
déplacements avaient en rôle de
chefferie de cabine est assez classique
organisation gestion des espaces gestion
des flux gestion du protocole relation
avec la préfecture relation avec les
interlocuteurs institutionnels du
territoire et dans une visite
préparatoire vous savez nous sommes
assez nombreux
la visite préparatoire et mener dirigé
par un membre de la chefferie de cabinet
et l'ensemble des services concourant
sont présents le ministère concerné
lorsque c'est le cas mais aussi les
services de presse de communication de
réalisation de sécurité ou d'intendance
cabourdin le rôle qu'ils jouent à leur
avait quelque chose à voir pour vous
avec la sécurité non le rôle de monsieur
benalla n'avait rien à voir avec
l'organisation du dispositif de sécurité
mais l'organisation globale général du
déplacement à laisser madame jourdain
au regard de ce que vous nous indiquer
quelle est à votre sens la nécessité
d'un port d'armes
c'est au genre de fonction comme je vous
le disais tout à l'heure je n'ai pas eu
à ma connaissance le port l'information
du port d'armes délivré par le préfet de
police
dès lors je ne connais ni l'objet de la
formulation de sa demande et au delà de
ça l'utilisation qui en est faite je ne
suis pas à même de vous dire
l'utilisation que monsieur benalla a
fait de ce port d'armes donc il est
difficile pour moi d'émettre en jugement
sur un élément qui relève de
l'organisation interne du palais de
l'elysée merci madame jourdain de
nouveau merci monsieur le président sur
l'autorisation de port d'armes de
monsieur b n'est là il est indiqué
missions de police ce que vous nous avez
décrit est il compatible avec cette
mission de police correspondent ils à
une mission de police
je vous ai pour ma part fait état de
l'investissement de monsieur benalla
dans ses qualités organisationnelles que
j'ai pu voir
je ne connais pas au delà que j'ai pu
organiser avec lui l'ensemble du champ
de ses missions
madame jourdain pas d'autres questions
comprenez monsieur girier que même si
vous n'êtes pas à même de répondre
personnellement en fonction des
attributions qui sont les vôtres à ces
questions elles sont tout de même assez
troublante car il ya une définition de
fonction qui ne semble pas avoir de
rapport avec la sécurité et un permis de
port d'armes qui est justifiée par le
prophète police dans le texte même des
considérants qui motive cette décision
par les attributions de sécurité de
police et de sécurité de monsieur ban à
la leçon n'exclut pas d'ailleurs que
subhanallah ait eu d'autre fonction que
de police mais ça semble attester que et
la présidence de la république a
transmis au préfet de police les
éléments nécessaires pour qu'il puisse
ainsi se prononcer sur une demande de
permis de port d'armes
alors peut-être que ce permis de port
d'armes attrait non pas aux fonctions
que monsieur mène à la exerçait auprès
du chef de cabinet pour la préparation
des déplacements publics du chef de
l'état mais comme il nous a été indiqué
qu' il était un responsable dé
l'organisation des déplacements privés
du chef de l'état c'est là que ses
compétences en matière de sécurité
donner toute leur mesure
et comme par ailleurs nous voyons
monsieur b nadal a accompagné le
président de la république dans un
certain nombre de déplacements et faire
barrage de son corps quand la foule est
un peu trop pressante
nous constatons qu'il avait de fait une
responsabilité de
protection rapprochée du chef de l'état
mais sans doute ne l'avez-vous pas perçu
directement
malgré la publicité qui a pu être donnée
monsieur deux rapporteurs vous vouliez
vous est une autre question
une précision lorsque vous avez eu
connaissance le 2 mai des faits avez
vous eu l'idée de construire au ministre
d'état de diligenter une enquête
administrative de saisir l'igpn sans
parler de la saisine de la justice eu
égard au fait que les événements étaient
particulièrement troublant d'une part et
que d'autre part ce de des
dysfonctionnements lourds sont avérés au
sein de la préfecture de police qui
dépend du ministère de l'intérieur en
particulier la le fait que monsieur ben
alla se trouve dans une réunion comme
vous l'avez dit débriefing et le fait
aussi que personne dans la chaîne de
commandement de la police
il y avait un responsable de la police
sur place place de la contrescarpe en
effet le moindre rapport au préfet de
police ou au ministère de l'intérieur
sur les événements qui se sont passés
je crois d'abord devoir rappeler qu'au
regard de cette vidéo je ne méconnais
pas la gravité des faits et je souhaite
d'ailleurs comme vous que toute la
vérité soit faite là-dessus de la
justice en est saisi le plus grave pour
moi utt donna d'avoir donne à voir de la
part de l'elysée
aucune réaction ni aucune sanction ce
qui n'a pas été le cas
d'abord il ne m'appartenait pas
personnellement de transmettre en
article 40 au procureur de la république
je ne suis pas fondée à agir dès
connaissance de la vidéo j'ai transmis
immédiatement tous les éléments à mon
autorité hiérarchique qui elle-même a
procédé aux diligences nécessaires avec
l'elysée et avec la préfecture de police
comme l'a rappelé le ministre lors de
son audition il appartenait à l'autorité
hiérarchique la plus à même d'apprécier
l'effet de transmettre le cas échéant en
article 40 au procureur est en outre
dans toute la chaîne décisionnelle
il est apparu que personne a estimé
opportun de le faire concernant
l'article 40 en particulier je
reviendrai après sur la question de
l'igpn le mist vous l'a dit dans la
pratique les ministres de l'intérieur
agissent quasi uniquement sur des faits
qui constituent des délits de presse
il n'a pas à se substituer à ceux qui
sont en responsabilité au plus près du
terrain pour recueillir les éléments et
effectuer le cas échéant des
signalements au delà sur la question du
gpn je vous rappelle qu'un signalement
avait été effectué sur la plateforme de
l'igpn auquel l'igpn a considéré ne pas
devoir donner suite et que par ailleurs
en l'occurrence nous n'étions pas dans
une situation où les auteurs de
violences étaient des policiers
or le rôle de l'igpn est aussi bien
d'assumer et d'assurer le suivi des
fonctionnaires de la police nationale
dans de telles situations
merci de votre réponse
s'agissant de l'article 40 nous avons eu
l'occasion plusieurs fois de le répéter
cet article 40 ne comporte aucune espèce
de restrictions sur la nature des
autorités publiques qui doivent le
mettre en mouvement
et si le ministre de l'intérieur s'est
fait pour lui même sa propre doctrine
à supposer même qu'elles correspondent à
celles de ses predict prédécesseur ça
n'est qu'une doctrine
car en réalité l'obligation pèse sur lui
comme sur toute autre autorité publique
dont on peut s'interroger et dire oui à
ce que les faits justifiaient vraiment
de déclencher l'article 40 et nous avons
interrogé plusieurs personnalités qui
sont en responsabilité qui aurait pu le
décider elles mêmes elles ont dit voilà
c'est d'apprécier ce que nous avons fait
et ses appréciations des autorités
préfectorales qui les ont présentés
devant nous les ont mutuellement
conforter mais la seule chose qui soit
absolument certaine c'est que en ce qui
concerne le procureur de la république
lui quand il a eu connaissance des faits
il n'a pas estimé qu'ils étaient en
dessous du niveau qui permette
l'ouverture d'une enquête préliminaire
puis d'une instruction et par conséquent
d'une certaine façon l'appréciation qui
a été fait par les différentes autorités
et hiérarchique jusqu'au ministre de
l'intérieur et au directeur du cabinet
du président de la république et celle
du procureur de la république de paris
divergent sur le point de savoir si le
délit était finalement suffisamment
important ou non pour justifier une
enquête préliminaire est une
ensuite une instruction donc
je crois que notre commission des lois
avec ses pouvoirs de commission
d'enquêté aura est tout de même à se
prononcer elle aussi sur ce point je
voudrais vous dire aussi que il serait
important pour nous de savoir si le
cabinet du ministre de l'intérieur a
demandé dès le mois de mai dans les
premiers jours qui ont suivi ce
dysfonctionnement du 1er mai à accéder
aux images de vidéo protection de la
ville de paris pour faire la lumière sur
les circonstances de l'intervention de
monsieur men à la place de la
contrescarpe est ce que le cabinet du
ministre s'est interrogé sur ce point
est ce que la demande a été faite
est ce qu'une autre autorité à votre
connaissance l'a fait il a fallu
attendre que l' affaire soit rendue
publique par un grand quotidien pour que
une enquête de l'igpn soit ouverte
est ce que ça veut dire que au fond on
se contente le 2 2 2 mais de savoir
premièrement qu'à présidence de la
république qui emploie monsieur ban est
là a été dûment informée de ce qui s'est
passé et deuxièmement que celle ci a
décidé une sanction ce qui semble avoir
épuisé toute autre réaction des pouvoirs
publics fassent ce dysfonctionnement
monsieur thiriez pour vous répondre sur
la vidéoprotection monsieur le président
en personne au sein du cabinet du
ministre d'état n'a demandé à avoir
accès nina accéder aux vidéos protection
de la ville de paris nous disposions de
la vidéo rendue publique sur les réseaux
sociaux par an militants politiques mais
rien d'autre
je ne sais pas à ma connaissance si une
autre autorité à solliciter en accès à
ces vidéos
je vous remercie madame jacky de remédie
à moins que les rapporteurs est encore
des questions je veux pas les priver de
les poser madame d'euromédis alors les
collègues doivent savoir qu'ils ont une
minute pour poser leurs questions chacun
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
chef de cabinet vous avez dit que vous
n'étiez pas à l'origine de la demande
d'équipements police de la voiture que
le permis de port d'armes
il vous avait été demandée mais que bon
c'était ça n'avait pas été accordée que
l'attribution du grade de lieutenant
colonel s'était pas vous non plus pour
une personne aussi proche du président
de la république comment se fait-il que
votre avis ne soit jamais pris en compte
vous êtes quand même le ministère de
l'intérieur et devriez être consultés
quand il s'agit de quelqu'un qui va être
si proche du président nigérien même la
sénatrice vous savez dans ces cas là
pour moi l'important est de savoir faire
la part des choses et si j'ai pu
effectivement travaillées côtoyé
emmanuel macron alors candidat désormais
président de la république je me suis
fixé une règle à son égard dans les
échanges que je peux avoir avec lui
c'est de ne jamais aborder les sujets
relatifs au ministère de l'intérieur
carte c'est pour moi une question
fondamentale de loyauté à l'égard de mon
ministre que je ne saurais court
circuité par ailleurs je veille au
regard de ces éléments à ne pas avoir
une quelconque ingérence dans les
relations de nature technique une
demande de port d'armes est une demande
technique entre des agents de la
présidence de la république et moi même
et comme je les dis dans mon propos
introductif en aucun cas et à aucun
moment je n'ai servi pour de quelconques
passe-droits entre monsieur benalla et
le ministre de l'intérieur mais le chef
de cabinet savez vous
- si le préfet de police quand il a
rendu sa décision était au courant du
refus que les services centraux du
ministère de l'intérieur avait opposé à
la même demande
je n'ai pas connaissance de cette
information je vous remercie madame de
la gontrie
merci monsieur le président monsieur
chef de cabinet vous l'avez bien compris
nous sommes soucieux et attentif et
préoccupé de la qualité de la sécurité
de la protection du président de la
république vous avez indiqué tout à
l'heure que vous n'aviez pas procéder
vous-même au recrutement d'alexandre
benalla dont vous avez précisé qu'il
avait été recruté en décembre 2016 par
le mouvement en marche
je pense qu'on peut être d'accord sur le
fait que trésorier si le contrat car il
est trésorier mais que ce n'est pas lui
qui prend la décision de recruter tel ou
tel dans une équipe de campagne du coup
nous ne savons pas qui a décidé de
recruter monsieur benalla mais ce
n'était pas tellement le sujet de ma
question lorsque ce recrutement j'ai
envie dire forme elle intervient en
décembre 2016
j'imagine qu'un certain nombre de
comment dire d'assurance de
vérifications sont faites de manière à
ce que le poste qui s'apprête à lui être
confiées vous l'avez rappelé tout à
leurs responsables de la sécurité soient
adaptés or il a été fait état d'au moins
deux incidents graves ayant concerné
monsieur benalla au moins de novembre à
bobigny le jour de la déclaration de
candidature du candidat macron au centre
et au cfa de bobigny puis dans les
locaux mêmes de en marche
le 24 novembre 2016 ma question est donc
est-ce que vous contestez l'existence de
ces incidents est ce que vous avez fait
vérifier là comment dire la fiabilité ou
la conformité de monsieur benalla au
poste que vous apprêtiez à lui confiée
par ce que vous voyez bien que sur
l'ensemble de ces sujets ce qui nous
préoccupe c'est l'adéquation entre le
comportement de ce monsieur et les
responsabilités qui ensuite
lui seront confiées dans un premier
temps par le mouvement politique dans un
deuxième temps par un président de la
république sur chef de cabinet madame la
sénatrice
pour répondre à votre question
concernant monsieur benalla dont je vous
ai indiqué avoir été avisé du
recrutement mais ne pas y avoir procédé
je ne connaissais pas l'antériorité de
son parcours j'avais à ma connaissance
quelques éléments par exemple le fait
qu'il se soit engagé au service d'ordre
du parti socialiste durant de nombreuses
années en particulier le fait qu'il ait
déjà agi sur une campagne présidentielle
ce qui lui confiait une certaine
expérience et qui était une forme de
plus value dans la démarche de mise en
place du dispositif de sécurité dans
marche
j'avais par ailleurs l'information selon
laquelle il aurait travaillé comme garde
du corps à l'office européen des brevets
ou encore l'action qu'il menait alors
auprès du délégué interministériel aux
autres maires concernant les faits que
vous évoquez je laisserai le
qualificatif de gravité à votre
appréciation pour une simple et bonne
raison que prenons le premier cas celui
de bobigny le jour où monsieur macron
annonce sa candidature à l'élection
professionne à l'élection présidentielle
je crois que beaucoup d'entre vous
connaissent ce qu'est une élection ce
qu'est une campagne et ce à quoi sert en
service d'ordre
dès lors dans un événement de ce type
que vous avez en l'occurrence en
militant politique qui vient perturber
en événements vous avez en service
d'ordre dont la mission est d'extraire
la personne de cette pièce je le
confirme
cela ne se fait généralement pas dans la
plus grande cordialité puisque c'est un
peu difficile
les personnes qui viennent perturber en
meeting ne le font pas
ou en tout cas le font généralement avec
une forme de tension certaine à laquelle
il faut savoir répondre et en
l'occurrence c'était le cas à bobigny
quant au second point auquel vous fait
écho je vous confirme en avoir entendu
parler
il s'agissait néanmoins pour moi de
conflits de voisinage de conflits
d'usagé et en aucun cas d'éléments qui
auraient été de nature à rompre la
confiance que nous pouvions à leur
accorder à monsieur benalla pour assurer
le dispositif de sécurisation de la
campagne qui je le rappelle portait sur
la sûreté et sur la sécurité
c'était un périmètre assez large sûreté
des bâtiments organisation de la
sécurisation et des dispositifs de
sécurisation du des meetings animations
et mobilisation de l'ensemble des
bénévoles du service d'ordre de la
campagne qui pour des meetings lorsque
vous arrivez à 15 20 25 mille personnes
peuvent comporter au sein du service
d'ordre
jusqu'à 300 400 personnes merci de votre
réponse madame tremblay ce président
ma question monsieur gérer je la place
dans le contexte de la campagne
présidentielle
vous étiez quand même un homme de
confiance une pièce maîtresse dans
l'organisation d'une campagne
présidentielle en avoir suivi quelques
unes
je pense ne pas me tromper même si
c'était dans d'autres temps que moi j'ai
assisté à des à des campagnes mais il me
semble qu'un directeur de campagne
connaît parfaitement le candidat mais
connaît parfaitement hausse également
toutes les personnes qui gravitent au
plus proche des candidats
donc je suis un petit peu surprise que
vous ne connaissiez pas plus que cela
le parcours que vous n'ayez pas bout
recruté sept personnes qui étaient au
plus proche de du président macron et on
se donne enfin du candidat à l'époque et
ma question est la suivante
à aucun moment vous n'avez été consulté
par le président de la république
lorsqu'il a recruté offre lorsqu'a été
recrutés monsieur benalla à la
présidence de la république alors vous
étiez l'homme de confiance pendant la
campagne et vous connaissez sans doute
au mieux tous toutes ces personnes qui
gravitaient autour du président monsieur
chef de cabinet mais si le chef de
cabinet de madame la sénatrice là la
question de la proximité
quelque part doit être
graduée si vous me posez la question
pour moi la proximité du président de la
république
en tout cas d' emmanuel macron candidat
à la présidentielle était davantage ses
conseillers en communication
ses conseillers sur le fond ses
conseillers organisant les déplacements
de la campagne ces conseillers
organisant les finances et les rh
davantage que ceux de la sécurité et en
l'occurrence durant la campagne
emmanuel macron n'avait à faire à
monsieur benalla que lorsqu'il était à
l'extérieur du siège de la campagne dans
le cadre de déplacements ou dans le
cadre deux meetings dès lors et je vous
redire elle la même réponse que j'ai pu
formuler à monsieur le président
monsieur macron n'avait pas devenu
président de la république à me
solliciter sur en quelconque avis à
émettre sur monsieur benalla dans le
cadre de sa campagne
certes il n'avait pas me faire mais
peut-être l'at-il fait tout de même
c'est la question de notre collègue est
en tout cas oui et je vous confirme
qu'il ne l'a pas fait le président de la
république s'est entouré de
collaborateurs a mis en oeuvre en place
a mis en place a mis en oeuvre ces
recrutements
pour ma part j'étais bien affairé avec
mon directeur de cabinet à organiser
l'équipe qui s'installait à l'hôtel de
beauvau est ce que monsieur chef de
cabine et d'autres membres de l'équipe
de sécurité de la campagne on tue après
l'élection présidentielle des fonctions
au sein de l'exécutif
que ce soit dans les ministères ou à
l'elysée à ma connaissance nous avons la
situation de monsieur kraz monsieur kraz
en qualité de gendarme réserviste
affecté à la garde républicaine qui a et
je n'en ai pas les preuves étaient
affectés auprès du commandement
militaire
de la présidence de la république et au
delà de ça j'ai uniquement connaissance
d'une personne qui au début de la
campagne avait assuré la sécurité du
président de la république et qui ayant
été réintégrés car il est un ancien
membre du gign ayant été réintégré à la
gendarmerie nationale est aujourd'hui au
jspr le siège du président de la
république
merci de cette réponse monsieur françois
pilet le président ma question vient
dans la droite ligne de cette liane vous
êtes reposé
imaginons qui est autour du président de
la république un certain nombre d'autres
contractuels dont la mission aurait un
rapport direct ou indirect avec la
sécurité du président est-ce qu il
serait concevable que vous ne sachiez
pas que vous ne connaissez pas je crois
de ce point de vue là que les choses
sont assez claires sur la sécurité de la
présidence nous avons d'un côté le gspr
pour la protection personnelle
individuelle et celle des déplacements
du président de la république le
commandement militaire pour la
sécurisation du palais et la préfecture
de police assurent la sécurité
périmétrique
il est bien évident que d'autres
personnes interagissent et nous en
serions informés mais ce n'est pas le
cas le gspr est commandée par le colonel
lavergne le commandement militaire par
le général bio farina qui sont les
interlocuteurs sur les grands enjeux de
sécurité et je me permettrai de rajouter
au delà de ça qu'à ma connaissance nous
n'avons pas eu d'incident majeur
mettant en cause ou ne garantissant pas
la sécurité du président de la
république lors de ses déplacements
information qui je l'espère serait
remonté au ministère de l'intérieur
voici alain richard j'ai plutôt des
questions pour nous rapporteur au
sentiment de la commission d' enquête
pour savoir comment nous progressons sur
le sujet de l'attribution
décisions répondant à une demande de
port d'armes
avons nous solliciter le formulaire de
demande puisque évidemment le
considérant qu'ils figurent dans la
décision se prononce sur les arguments
de la demande
donc cette demande émane je le présume
de du cabinet du président de la
république elle a été établie par
quelqu'un est donc plutôt que de revenir
dix fois sur le sujet avons-nous fait le
chaînage entre la demande et la décision
individuelle du préfet de police
j'aurai pour tout de suite à monsieur
alain richard qu'effectivement cette
demande a été faite au ministère de
l'intérieur dont nous attendons la
réponse
deuxièmement ce point mais tu es venu à
l'esprit déjà et je n'avais pas pensé à
poser la question mais c'est la
préfecture de police qui se comprend
bien exploite pour tous les sujets dans
public est d'ailleurs de circulation le
réseau de vieillot protection de la
ville de paris avons-nous le dispositif
1 le l'élément de suppose contractuels
qui organise la consultation permanente
par la préfecture de police d'une du
réseau de vidéoprotection de la ville de
paris que compte tenu de la
réglementation spécifique à la police
administrative à la police municipale à
paris je suppose que c'est le droit
commun mais du fait que des questions se
posent sur l'accès à ces documents vidéo
je pense que le plus simple est que nous
ayons la base de textes
enfin dernier point qui est une simple
observation à propos d
des étapes qui ont conduit au
recrutement de monsieur benalla j'ai
quelques expériences du fonctionnement
du service d'ordre du parti socialiste
c'est le seul que je connaisse à vrai
dire je pense qu'il faisait référence
depuis longtemps et que donc le fait d'y
avoir servi durablement et être en soi
un argument de recrutement
madame et monsieur le rapporteur avait
vu quelque chose à jeter peut-être la
question sur la vidéoprotection c'est
une demande intéressante je ne sais pas
si nous l'avons déjà fait mais elles
pourraient être le fait on pourrait tout
à fait me donner suite à la proposition
d'un à richard est demandée ce document
que nous n'avons pas demandé par
opposition aux précédents que vous avez
cités non je voulais juste dire un mot
sur le mot interagir donc vous
considérez que monsieur benalla neigeux
n'a pas interagit par rapport à
l'ensemble du dispositif de sécurité du
président de la république
bien qu'il dispose d'un port d'armes aux
récentes police et bien qu'il dispose
d'une voiture police dont on ne sait pas
d'ailleurs au juste par qui il a été
décidé de la mettre en place
e et j'ajouterais encore un mot si le
président le permet par rapport à cette
relative opacité qui apparaît
bizarrement entre le ministère de
l'intérieur et la préfecture de police
parce que comment expliquer qu alors
qu'un personnage qui n'avait rien à
faire là arrivent dans un accoutrement
qui vous a d'ailleurs étonné monsieur
chef de cabinet dans une réunion de
commandement
il n'y a pas d'explication demandez pas
de réaction du ministère de l'intérieur
et d'autre part je reprécise parce que
tout à l'heure vous n'avez pas apporté
de réponse il y avait bien un
responsable de la police place de la
contrescarpe celui ci voyant les
agissements des deux personnes vont
cerner
il aurait dû quand même pour le moins
rendre compte et on pourrait penser vu
la qualité de ces personnes que le
préfet de police aurait pour le moins
rendu compte au ministère de l'intérieur
pourquoi cela n'a pas eu lieu et quelles
conséquences en tirer vous monsieur le
chef de cabinet alors pour répondre
monsieur le rapporteur à votre question
ou plutôt vos questions tout d'abord
monsieur pénale a n'a pas à ma
connaissance interagit avec les services
de sécurité
deuxième point concernant son véhicule
je crois sur ce point là qu'une réponse
a pu être apportée par le général
dirigeants le commandement militaire à
savoir que ce véhicule était en véhicule
de la présidence de la république
équipé par la présidence de la
république sur l'opacité évoqué entre le
ministère de l'intérieur
et cette grande maison qu'est la
préfecture de police
avec plus de 40 mille agents
si on a bonne mémoire monsieur le préfet
de police lui même n'était pas informé
de la venue de monsieur benalla dans la
salle de commandement
en ce 1er mai vous savez le ministre de
l'intérieur voit lui remonté en grand
nombre d'informations mais il est à la
tête d'un ministère de près de trois
cent mille personnes
tous ne lui remontent pas et vous l'avez
vu et vous avez pu le lire dans le
rapport igpn qui vous a été remis
vendredi où nous pouvons prendre
connaissance de l'information selon
laquelle le major accompagnant monsieur
benalla écrase au regard de la qualité
de monsieur benalla
ne s'est pas trouvée fondé à faire
remonter l'information peut être at il
été impressionné comme l'a évoqué
monsieur le président mais tel a été le
cas au delà sur le reste je crois que
ces informations seront éclairés par
l'instruction judiciaire en cours
oui monsieur chef de cabinet sans
assister trop lourdement sur ce point la
question de notre rapporteur ne portait
pas sur le major qui effectivement est
un agent je crois de grande qualité mais
dont le grade ne lui a pas paru
justifier qu il s'interpose ou même
qu'il fasse un rapport
mais la question de notre rapporteur
c'était il y avait bien un commissaire
de police qui étaient là d'ailleurs ce
commissaire de police nous en avons
entendu parler
à partir du 19 juillet il y avait bien
un commissaire de police qui étaient là
comment se fait-il qu'il n'ait pas fait
rapport de cette situation à tel point
qu'il a fallu qu'il y ait une vidéo qui
circule pour que vous
disiez avoir été informé de ce qui
s'était produit de même que que l'elysée
or quand vous voyez la vidéo vous trouvé
ça très important et vous avez rappelé
tout à l'heure dans la journée du 2 mai
ce qui s'est produit les échanges
d'informations entre l'elysée et le
cabinet du ministre de l'intérieur
mais quand on vous pose la question de
savoir si un rapport aurait dû être fait
par le commissaire de police place de la
contrescarpe en réalité vous ne nous
répondait pas mais vous pourriez juste
nous dire oui ce rapport n'a pas été
vrai je veux pas vous soufflez la
réponse ce rapport n'aurait pas été n'a
pas été fait il aurait bien dû être fait
parce que c'était grave
c'est pas parce qu'il y avait chaque
jour des milliers de rapports à
l'autorité hiérarchique que celui là
n'aurait pas été plus important que les
autres vous avez jugez vous même de
l'importance de la situation à partir de
la vidéo aux pointes de d'ouvrir un
dialogue avec la présidence de la
république
c'est juste ça vous voyez qui qui nous
qui nous préoccupe un petit peu monsieur
chef de cabinet vous avez la parole
monsieur le président je ne porterai pas
de jugement sur l'appréciation qui a pu
être celle temps du commissaire qui
était présent sur place que du
commandant de la compagnie de crs se
rappelle au regard des éléments dont
nous disposons que le commandant de la
compagnie de crs présente indiqué que
ses effectifs par exemple étaient
persuadés d'avoir à faire des
fonctionnaires de police en civil
au regard de ces éléments je vous
confirme qu'aucune note
à ma connaissance n'est remonté au
ministre une fois de plus je crois que
désormais l enquête judiciaire va
pouvoir déterminer d'éventuelles
responsabilités des fonctionnaires de
police présents sur place en vérité bien
sûr nous vous savez combien nous sommes
respectueux
d d attribution de la justice et
soucieux de la séparation des pouvoirs
c'est même l'une des réseaux qui a
justifié les déclenchements de notre
commission de notre vision d'information
dotée des pouvoirs d'une d'une
commission denquête mais tout ce qui
concerne non pas les faits délictueux
reprocher à monsieur benalla mais le
fonctionnement de la hiérarchie
administrative et est au coeur de la
préoccupation et il n'est pas du tout
certain que le juge ait le moins du
monde à se prononcer sur l'opportunité
des réactions administratives qui ont eu
lieu ou plutôt qu'ils n'ont pas eu lieu
après la constatation des faits et du
coup de nous sautons pleinement investis
de la compétence nous d'aller regarder
le fonctionnement des administrations et
d'éventuels dysfonctionnements ce qui
justifie des questions qui qui vous sont
posées la réserve de l'instruction
judiciaire et ne paraît pas totalement
pertinente en l'occurrence mais enfin la
question était posée vous y avez répondu
tels que vous souhaitiez le faire et
nous en prenons acte madame lherbier oui
monsieur le chef de cabinet revenir à
justement la période de la campagne
monsieur b nabeul a donc été recrutés
sur expérience l'a dit les antécédents
du parti socialiste éventuellement
expérience limitée il avait quand même
que 26 ans donc
alors moi je voulais savoir si et à
l'époque il avait nettement moins de 6
ans effectivement moi je voudrais savoir
est-ce qu'ils avaient des diplômes est
ce que parce que gérer des flux vous
nous avez dit gérer des flux gérer des
personnes il avait un port d'armes à
l'intérieur du siège vous nous l'avez
dit c'est quand même pas rien certes la
communication est essentielle mais la
sécurité me semble encore plus essentiel
dirons nous parce qu'on était encore
dans une période en plus vigipirate et
période de terroristes donc je voudrais
savoir sassi qui a pu vérifier les
diplômes quand on sait que quand on
recrute un policier municipal toutes les
obligations administratives qui nous
incombe de vérification des antécédents
etc
ça me semble quand même aberrant qu'une
personne si proche du président on n'est
pas plus vérifié que ça ses compétences
la deuxième chose si vous me permettez
monsieur le chef de cabinet concerne
justement les points d'enregistrement
tout à l'heure monsieur le préfet de
région nous a dit que pour préparer une
sécurisation d'un site
on sait tous les points d'enregistrement
on connaît tous les endroits qui ont été
sources d'enregistrement ce qui m'étonne
c'est que à la suite justement deux de
ces problèmes tout de suite quand on a
su qu'il y avait une vidéo qui était qui
interpellait la réflexion comment se
fait-il que le ministère de l'intérieur
n'ait pas demandé tout de suite
systématiquement tous les points d'eau
vidéo qui existaient et tous les lieux
de constatation de l'activité que
pouvait avoir monsieur benalla sur place
si vous me permettez
alors monsieur chef de cabinet rahm la
sénatrice et merci de vos questions je
vais essayer de les prendre dans l'ordre
bon monsieur benalla était-il trop jeune
j'aurais tendance à vous dire que la
qualité n'attend pas forcément le nombre
des années c'est un directeur de
campagne de 32 ans pour une
présidentielle qui vous le dit sur la
question de son poste en quoi consistait
le poste de directeur de la sûreté de la
sécurité car occuper
alexandre benallal s'occupait de la
gestion du parc automobile
la sécurisation du qg de la campagne la
gestion de tout le volet sécurité de
l'organisation des meetings l'animation
des nombreux bénévoles du service
d'ordre
la sécurité des déplacements
concernant c'est qu'elle est ce que
excusez moi dans les tous les maux
compte est ce que ça veut dire qu' il
n'avait pas de fonction de protection
rapprochée autrement dit qu'il n'avait
pas de fonction de garde du corps aussi
pendant cette période là je crois que de
ce point de vue là vous posez un
monsieur le président une question qui
est intéressante dans le déroulement
chronologique d'une campagne
il faut savoir que le jour où emmanuel
macron ministre de l'économie a
démissionné il s'est retrouvé du jour au
lendemain sans aucune protection de
l'état économique et la fonction
ministérielle avait pas de pression non
plus il a dû c'est normal n'est pas
évoquée il a dû jusqu au mois de janvier
organisée en démarrage de campagne
électorale sans protection mines en mise
en oeuvre par l'état
par conséquent le mouvement en marche a
mis en place une sécurité privée pour
monsieur macron je le rappelle qu'à
l'époque nous avons eu des meetings
jusqu'à 25000 personnes
c'est pas rien nous avons eu de très
nombreux déplacements il convenait
d'apporter une sécurité à une
personnalité alors en vue
dès lors que la sécurité du candidat
les manuels macron a été assuré par
l'état par des agents et des
fonctionnaires de police du sdlp nous
n'avons alors au sein du mouvement en
marche plus assurer la protection
physique la bulle individuelle du
candidat jusqu'à la fin de la campagne
qui a été prise en compte de manière
progressive par l'état mais monsieur
monsieur macron des candidats que le 16
novembre
oui monsieur monsieur macron est
candidat le 16 novembre et monsieur
macron dispose d'une protection par
l'état au mois de janvier
oui monsieur le président pour pour
répondre à la question d'un homme la
sénatrice concernant sa situation je
dois je crois devoir rappeler la
situation administrative de monsieur
benalla qui sans revenir sur ses
diplômes doit être regardée également on
regarde la réglementation applicable sur
les activités privées de sécurité
et voici les éléments relatifs à sa
situation qui ont été fournies par le
conseil national des activités privées
de sécurité le cnaps sa carte
professionnelle d'agent de sécurité lui
a été délivré en février 2014 et est
valable jusqu'en février 2019
elle fait suite à une première carte
délivrée en 2011 cette carte comporte
les mentions suivantes protection
physique des personnes surveillance
humaine ou surveillance par des systèmes
électroniques de sécurité ou gardiennage
transport de fonds sûreté aéroportuaire
opérateurs de vidéoprotection il est
également titulaire depuis juillet 2018
d'un agrément de dirigeants de sociétés
de sécurité privées
l'ensemble de ces autorisations lui ont
été délivrés conformément aux procédures
en vigueur et les enquêtes de moralité
réalisés dans ce cadre semble ne pas
avoir fait apparaître d'éléments
s'opposant à la délivrance de ces
agréments pour terminer sur la question
et votre dernière question relative aux
enregistrements
je tiens également rappelé la
chronologie
dès lors
que le cabinet du ministre le 2 mai au
matin à disposer de l'information selon
laquelle monsieur benalla serait
intervenue dans le cadre d'une opération
de maintien de l'ordre
l'autorité hiérarchique comme l'autorité
préfectorale ont été dûment avisé dès
lors ce n'est pas au ministre à son
cabinet d'aller voir et d'aller demander
immédiatement ses vidéos
c'est à l'autorité au plus près du
terrain de s'enquérir en l'occurrence je
ne suis pas en mesure de vous répondre
sur les suites qui ont été données je
vous remercie monsieur le président
tueur monsieur le chef de cabinet à
votre connaissance
monsieur benalla at il créé une société
de sécurité privée ou avait-il préparer
les choses pour le faire à ma
connaissance hommes se rapporte à
rallonge quelle était l'utilité de la
mention de l'agrément comme directeur de
jeu société je vous ai fait mention
monsieur le rapporteur des éléments
transmis par le cnaps merci bien
alors nous allons continuer mes chers
collègues madame de la gontrie a déjà
posé une question mais elle souhaitait
rebondir sur les changes que nous avons
eu je crois et donc je lui redonne la
parole
merci monsieur le président pour pour
aller dans le sens des questions posées
par notre collègue alain richard qui se
souciait de deux fondements de
l'existence des vidéos alors peut-être
préciser à nos collègues que les vidéos
qui sont le système de vidéosurveillance
qui se trouve sur paris est appliquée
dans le cadre dispositif du plan zonal
de vidéoprotection d'île de france
il y a eu une délibération du conseil de
paris en 2009 une convention et l'âge
répond alain richard 24 février 2010 ce
qui est facile et qui est à trouver en
ligne qui indique que ces vidéos sont la
propriété de l'état qui sont en charge
de son qui est en charge sont de leur
déploiement de leur fonctionnement et de
leur maintenance
l'accord de paris n'ayant été sollicité
que pour l'accord sur l'implantation
l'autorisation d'implantation sur la
voirie municipale l'exonération de la
redevance d'occupation du domaine public
et le subvention du fonctionnement ça
c'était pour répondre à nos collègues
monsieur le président ma question est
très simple j'écoutais tout à l'heure
monsieur girier concernant le rôle de
monsieur benalla concernant la
protection il a insisté si j'ai bien
compris sur l'exclusivité de la
compétence du gspr danse dans ce cas
comment expliquez-vous ce que monsieur
benalla a révélé l'autre soir au jt de
20h de tf1 à savoir qu'il était armé
lorsqu'il accompagnait le président de
la république dans ses déplacements
privés
monsieur girier permettez-moi dans un
premier temps de rebondir sur la
remarque de madame la sénatrice
relatives à la vidéo surveillance pour
appeler en détail d'abord des vidéos les
images relève dans quatre de
conservation et d'exploitation
extrêmement strictes qui est défini à
l'article l de 150 2 1 et suivants du
code de la sécurité intérieure
l'installation des systèmes de
vidéoprotection est soumise à
l'autorisation de la cnil
l'accès en est limité aux agents
individuellement désignés et dûment
habilités des services de police et de
gendarmerie nationale ainsi que des
douanes et des services d'incendié et de
secours
par ailleurs la durée de conservation
des images est limité à en moi sauf
nécessité de les conserver pour les
besoins d'une procédure pénale et
surtout passé ce délai l'article du code
de la sécurité intérieure prévoit
expressément que les enregistrements
doivent être détruits
deuxième point relatif aux mentions dans
les médias ces derniers jours de
monsieur benalla je n'ai pas de
commentaire à faire
je n'en ai pas connaissance je n'étais
pas présent sur ces événements comme je
voulais dit tout à l'heure où je ne suis
pas en mesure de vous le confirmer et je
n'en ai pas l'information
bien la parole et à madame catherine di
folco merci monsieur le président je
suis désolé on va peut-être sauter un
petit peu du coq à l'âne mais comme
j'étais inscrite à un moment je voulais
revenir un peu sur le statut d
observateur qui semble être un statut un
peu flou donc monsieur benalla a été
observateur sur cette manifestation du
1er mai mais vous paraît-il normal que
les observateurs assistent à des
réunions de préparation à des réunions
de débriefing par la suite interne sur
des opérations de maintien de l'ordre
autour du ministère de l'intérieur du
ministre de l'intérieur pardon et et de
hauts responsables de la police
nationale donc
vous nous l'avez dit il était aussi
accompagnée de monsieur kraz est-ce que
d'autres observateurs peuvent être
admis à ce type de réunion avec
reconnaissance monsieur de chef de
cabinet madame la sénatrice
je crois que de ce point de vue là le
rapport igpn qui a été rendu public
vendredi apporte à la fois des
éclairages sur l'ensemble de ces points
et permet aussi de nous donner quelques
perspectives
d'abord je crois que il y a une réelle
nécessité de poursuivre d'ailleurs
d'amplifier la présence d'observateurs
au sein de la police et de la
gendarmerie
c'est une pratique qui contribue à une
meilleure connaissance de l'action des
forces de l'ordre et au lien de
confiance qu'on peut avoir et qui doit
exister entre les forces de sécurité
intérieure et la population chercheurs
élus magistrats journalistes
il est important d'avoir en certain
nombre de ces personnes qui viennent
partager
on ne serait ce que l'espace d'une
journée ce que représente aujourd'hui la
vie de nos forces de sécurité
de ce point de vue là sur les présence
d'observateurs le rapport igpn a pu
démontrer que à la fois il n'y a pas de
pratiques uniformes
nous n'avons pas forcément de cadre
fixant les conditions d'autorisation
d'accueil des observateurs et de leur
présence lors d'opérations de police et
de surcroît pas d'identification
spécifique des observateurs sauf parfois
des journalistes
et je crois même la sénatrice que vos
remarques rejoignent une partie des
conclusions de l'igpn avec la nécessité
de mieux encadrer à la fois en ayant des
briefings en amont et débriefing à
l'issue pour expliquer la conduite à
tenir la bonne distance à avoir et en
même temps expliqué à l'issue quel a été
le travail des forces de sécurité de ce
point de vue là l'igpn suggère la mise
en place d'une charte type rappelant les
grands principes qui doivent présider à
l'accueil des observateurs leurs droits
leurs devoirs et le positionnement lire
chic suffisant du référent il invite
également à une signature systématique
d'une convention avec l'observateur et
enfin le rapport iv p n invite au port
d'un signe distinctif permettant
d'identifier l'observateur sans
ambiguïté je crois que le ministre
d'état saura dans les tout prochains
jours se saisir de ce rapport igpn pour
permettre à l'avenir de maintenir dans
un cadre désormais mieux organisés et
mieux réguler la présence des
observateurs
merci monsieur de chef de cabinet
monsieur jacques bigot président vous
avez indiqué que jerry était entendu à
la fois comme chef de cabinet du
ministre l'intérieur mais également
comme le directeur de campagne du
président de la crique il monsieur
girier en cette qualité de directeur de
campagne
vous avez vous pouvez nous préciser
qu'elle était dans la campagne la place
à ma connaissance éminente de gérard
collomb nous avaient indiqué qu'ils
étaient des fonctions de monsieur
benalla dans l'organisation des meetings
est ce que il vous est très semblable
que le ministre de l'intérieur n'est pas
connue ne sache pas qui était monsieur
bénard là lorsqu'ils le rencontrent avec
vous da par avance que vous avez dire
plusieurs reprises monsieur le chef de
cabinet
concernant place de monsieur gérard
collomb alors maire de lyon et président
de la métropole de lyon dans le cadre de
la campagne de monsieur macro je crois
que cette place c'était la place d'un
élu engagé et investi pour en projet
auprès d'un candidat à la présidentielle
il rencontrait régulièrement le
président de la république il échangé
ensemble ils partageaient tant sur le
fond que sur la forme un certain nombre
de discussions mais vous pensez bien et
je vous la teste que lors de ces
réunions monsieur benalla n'était pas
présent et si monsieur collomb a pu
rencontrer durant la campagne
monsieur benalla il ne l'a croisé que de
vue il l'a vu dans des circulations il
l'a vu devant une porte dans backstage
il l'a vu à proximité d'un véhicule à un
départ de cortège
mais jamais à aucun moment il ne s'est
trouvé dans une réunion de travail
quelconque en sa présence
dès lors il le connaissait de vue mais
comme je voulais dit il ne connaissait
ni son nom ni son prénom ni ses
fonctions merci de cette réponse madame
canayer oui merci monsieur le président
monsieur le chef de cabinet vous dis
qu'effectivement vous étiez dans les
premières personnes qui ont été informé
des agissements de monsieur bénard a le
1er mai et que vous avez eu pris toutes
les mesures qui s'imposaient en
saisissant vos autorités hiérarchiques
moi je voudrais vous poser trois
questions la première c'est à quelle
date à quel moment avez vous connu la
nature de la sanction qui a été
prononcée à l'encontre de monsieur
benalla avez vous eu l'occasion il a été
informé de la présence de monsieur
benalla sur des événements postérieurs à
la mise en oeuvre de cette sanction et a
fortiori aurait été avez vous été
informé ou avez vous eu connaissance ou
avez vous constaté des comportements de
monsieur benalla qui dépassaient ses
nouvelles fonctions plus protocolaire
qui lui étaient attribués après sa
rétrogradation le chef de cabinet
merci madame la sénatrice pour vous
répondre je rappelle ce n'est pas a été
informée le 1er mai mais le 2 mai au
matin concernant la nature de la
sanction
mon directeur de cabinet et moi même
avons été informés par le directeur de
cabinet de la présidence
le 2 mai au soir qu'une sanction allait
être prises nous n'en avons pas connu la
nature et donc de ce point de vue là je
n'ai pas eu des changes
concernant la période durant laquelle
une sanction a été établi je dois vous
avouer que peut-être pendant en moi je
n'ai pas eu à faire à monsieur benalla
et comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure j'ai eu sur le mois de juillet
pas mal des changes avec lui relatifs à
des événements se déroulant au palais
enfin sur son comportement
je dois vous dire que le 2 mai au matin
lorsque j'ai découvert la vidéo je les
regardais plusieurs fois pour y croire
parce que la personne que j'ai connu
pendant la campagne électorale n'était
en aucun cas violente et au contraire
dans des climats bien peu sera temps des
climat de très fortes tensions comme on
peut connaître dans une campagne
présidentielle
c'était au contraire quelqu'un qui
savait gérer son stress et garder son
calme et donc je vous avoue avoir été
particulièrement surpris de le voir dans
de telles conditions
merci de votre réponse monsieur qui
rouge oui monsieur bigot m'a devancé
mais j'ai une autre une autre question
monsieur le chef de cabinet le général
bio-farina déclaré que vincent kraz
étaient présents n'ont pas comme
réserviste mais comme simple citoyen le
jour du le jour du 1er mai est ce que
est ce que vous vous êtes escaut
ministère de l'intérieur s'est enquis du
statut exact de monsieur kraz ce jour là
sachant que celui-ci à ma connaissance
s'est vu suspendre delà de la réserve
officiel de la présidence dans
l'intervalle en opérationnel de la
présidence le 3 mai et que ce n'est pas
le cas en ce qui les concerne la réserve
opérationnelle
quel est donc est-ce qu'il va y avoir
une décision au sein du ministère de
l'intérieur le concernant et pourquoi
n'at-elle pas encore eu lieu
ce chef de cabinet concernant la
présence de monsieur kraz le premier
mais je me permets de vous faire lecture
de la page 13 du rapport qui a été rendu
public par l'igpn vendredi alexandre
benalla est accompagné pour la
circonstance son arrivée à la préfecture
de police d'une seconde personne qu'il
présente comme un collaborateur en
l'occurrence monsieur vincent kraz le
majeur misère ce qui ne connaît pas
monsieur kraz mais ne ne demande pas
d'explication compte tenu du statut de
monsieur benalla représentant affiché
est reconnu comme tel par sa hiérarchie
de la présidence de la république
voilà donc concernant ce point
concernant le statut
deux réservistes de monsieur kraz je
crois que la gendarmerie nationale s'est
exprimé sur ce point en fin de semaine
ils sont à ce stade dans une période de
suspension et la gendarmerie nationale
et le ministère de l'intérieur
s'exprimeront ultérieurement
après l'instruction judiciaire sur les
suites qui seront données pour les
contrats de réservistes de monsieur kraz
et de monsieur benalla le chef de
cabinet il ya aussi cette délivrance le
9 juillet dernier d'un agrément de
dirigeants d'entreprises de sécurité qui
a interrogé beaucoup de nos concitoyens
comment expliquer qu'un tel agrément ait
pu lui être délivré à cette date compte
tenu des fonctions monsieur benalla
occupait encore à l'elysée et dans la
procédure du cnaps puisque c'est le
monde l'organisme qui instruit et ses
demandes
est ce qu'il y a eu une enquête de
moralité qui a été conduite à cette
occasion et si oui comment expliquer que
l'agrément lui était donnée alors même
qu'il se trouvait dans une situation qui
avait donné lieu à une sanction
monsieur le président pour vous répondre
sur ce point e
je vous rappelle que cet agrément a été
délivré par le cnaps je n'en connais pas
les motivations et donc sur ce point
c'est l'intéressé seul qui pourrait nous
répondre sur l'objet de cet agrément
dirigeante de sociétés privées de
sécurité
je vous rappelle mais cet organisme
est un organisme qui intervient sous la
tutelle du ministre de l'intérieur
en effet si peut-être que vous n'avez
pas une réponse plus précise à la
question que je pose peut-être que votre
directeur de cabinet qui vient à 14h30
qui aura d'ici là l'occasion d'une
information plus complète pour à nous
répondre
au delà de la réponse que vous êtes en
train de nous faire et j'ai interrompu
ce vous demande devant d'excusés et donc
continuer je crois que le message est
transmis
s'il nous regarde par ailleurs vous avez
d'autres canaux peut-être pour le lui
faire savoir
par ailleurs concernant les enquêtes de
moralité je voulais confirme à la fois
sur les antécédents judiciaires sur les
fiches police et ses enquêtes de
moralité sont toujours réservés dans ce
cadre-là par le comte par le cnaps je
vous remercie
je vais donner la parole maintenant à
monsieur le président cambon qui comme
chacun sait n'est pas membre de la
commission des lois puisqu'il préside la
commission de la défense et des affaires
étrangères
mais à ce titre il a une grande
expérience des questions de sécurité ce
qui est faux tout à fait sa légitimité à
vous poser une question
merci monsieur le président et j'avais
effectivement attendu que les membres de
la commission des lois puisse s'exprimer
je vais revenir un instant sur la sphère
du port d'armes de monsieur benalla
comme l'a évoqué madame lherbier ma
collègue n'importe quel maire de france
lorsqu'il sollicite pour un policier
municipal
le permis de port d'armes suit les
règles que vous ministère de l'intérieur
imposé à très juste titre à savoir une
enquête approfondie mais surtout une
formation et un entraînement qui peuvent
déboucher effectivement sur une double
autorisation et du préfet du département
et du procureur de la république et qui
peut prendre parfois plusieurs mois et
qui permet effectivement un policier
municipal dont c'est la profession et
qui a subi un concours de pouvoir
bénéficier du permis de port d'un dock
ma question est simple
quelle quelle formation monsieur benalla
at il reçu pour bénéficier d'un port
d'armes
avez-vous des renseignements précis sur
les séances d'entraînement qu'il a pu
subir
puisque cette personne est à proximité
immédiate du chef de l'état
et par ailleurs est-ce qu'il ya d'autres
personnes qui bénéficient en un port
d'armes ont été dispensés d'une manière
ou d'une autre de cette séquence
extrêmement longue et extrêmement
difficile qui consiste à bénéficier d'un
permis de port d'armes pour pouvoir
exercer cette mission de sécurité
cette chef de cabinet monsieur le
sénateur je me permettrai de vous
répondre
pour la période relative à la campagne
électorale
considérant sur la période élyséenne qui
ne m'appartient pas de porter une
appréciation quelconque et je n'ai pas
connaissance
d'abord sur les instructions de port
d'armes
je vous confirme qu'il ya une
instruction par la dlp agit au ministère
de l'intérieur et la vie de plusieurs
services renseignements territoriale
l'unité de coordination de lutte
antiterroriste et à vis du dgpn
je tiens néanmoins à rappeler que
monsieur benalla s'est vu délivrer une
autorisation de port d'armes en octobre
2017 sur un fondement différend sur le
fondement du code de la sécurité
intérieure sans que le cabinet du
ministre ministres en aient été informés
auparavant monsieur benalla disposait
dans port d'armes durant la campagne
présidentielle il était à titre
personnel tireurs sportifs
mais je ne saurai vous apporter
d'éléments précis sur les exercices et
le nombre de tirs réglementaire et
régulier qu'il a pu effectuer je vous
remercie monsieur kuipers
merci monsieur le président au fur et à
mesure de l'audition qui sont menées par
cette commission
j'ai un sentiment peut-être que trop
personnelle d'avoir affaire monsieur
vinolas comme étant un électron libre à
savoir même que le jour où s'est passé
cet événement il a dit que lui même il
avait fait un acte citoyen il a déclaré
en disant allez aider les forces de
police dans ma première question est ce
que les forces de police étaient
insuffisantes ce jour là mais plus
précisément
j'aurais voulu savoir de qui dépend
directement les rares chic mans mathieu
béda la question simple toutes deux
messieurs le chef de cabinet nateur
question simple réponse simple la
hiérarchie de monsieur benalla est assez
simple il est chargé de mission auprès
du chef de cabinet du président de la
république son n + 1 et donc le chef de
cabinet du président de la république
qui a au dessus comme autorité le
président le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république concernant la
situation dans laquelle se trouvaient
les forces de police tu sur la place de
la contrescarpe je crois sur ce point
que ce sera à l'instruction et à la
justice d'éclaircir ces faits et je ne
me permettrais pas de les qualifie
monsieur ok merci monsieur le président
monsieur le chef de cabinet devrait
revenir aux propos liminaire vous avez
tenu vous avez dit que à propos des
éventuels passe-droits de dont a pu
bénéficier monsieur bénalia que vous
avez rappelé vous avez dit précisément
que monsieur bénard à n'avait bénéficié
d'aucun traitement privilégié par mon
intermédiaire et le président bharrat
pète alors que les mots chaque mot
compte effectivement est-ce que donc
vous avez bien dit par mon intermédiaire
faut-il comprendre par là que monsieur
benalla aurait pu bénéficier de
certaines faveurs de la part d'autres
intermédiaires extérieur au ministère de
l'intérieur si je puis dire monsieur
chef de cabinet monsieur le sénateur
vous comprendrez quand la match
r je ne suis pas fondés à apporter une
appréciation sur d'autres interventions
que les miennes très bien mes chers
collègues
si vous n'avez pas d'autres questions si
monsieur le rapporteur
les photos qui circulent faisant état de
la présence de monsieur benalla avec le
président de la république de tout su et
à porquerolles sont elles des faux
grossier je n'en ai aucune idée
je vous remercie notre audition est donc
déterminé je vais lever la séance tout
en vous rappelant que nous nous
retrouvons mes chers collègues à 14h30
nous auditionnons monsieur stéphane
fratacci qui est directeur du cabinet du
ministre d'état ministre de l'intérieur
sa séance est levée